in Dresden sind die Haltestellenschilder
bei Bussen und Bahnen seit Jahrzehnten
gelb das verstoße gegen die Gesetzeslage
sagen plötzlich die Behörden kein Witz
alle Schilder in der Stadt müssen
umlackiert werden statt gelb muss weiß
und das haltestellenhaar Kosten allein
fürs Material satte 300.000 Euro
man kann hier Straßen die
Straßenbahnhaltestellen gut erkennen und
deswegen ja ist es kompletter
Schwachsinn ich kenne die Schulter nur
so früher war es bis in der normale
Stange mit dem grünen haltestellenschild
was rund war und es ging auch
schlecht ich habe eine Brille aber die
Schilder habe ich immer gesehen ich kann
es nicht nachvollziehen bei der Dresdner
Polizei fällt vor kurzem jemandem auf
dass an den städtischen Haltestellen
wohl unrechtmäßige Zustände herrschen
das Haar steht auf gelben Grund
eigentlich müsste das Haar aber auf
weißem Grund stehen da gebe es seit 20
Jahren eine Regelung in der
Straßenverkehrsordnung nun setzt sich
eine bürokratische Maschine Gang die
Polizei sagt dem Landesamt für Verkehr
bescheid das Amt weiß die Stadt am tätig
zu werden die Stadt wiederum fordert die
Verkehrsbetriebe auf etwas zu
unternehmen Ergebnis sage und schreibe
1600 Schilder müssen für viel Geld
erneuert werden aber selbst die
Verkehrsbetriebe wissen nicht was diese
teure Umbaumaßnahme bringen soll
die Haltestellen waren nach unserem
Dafürhalten auch für Fahrgäste ganz gut
erkennbar
wir kann mich auch nicht entsehen dass
es mal irgendwie ein Kundenanliegen
gegeben hätte wo
Fahrgäste gesagt dann wir haben die
Haltestelle nicht gefunden weil die eben
nur auf gelben Grund zu sehen war wir
fragen im Bundesverkehrsministerium nach
was ist mit der Regelung auf sich hat
die in Dresden jetzt zum teuren
schildertausch führt die Thematik der
abweichenden Farbgebung von trägertafeln
wurde im zuständigen bundländer
Fachausschuss besprochen hierbei wurde
darauf hingewiesen dass die weiße
trägertafel auf Wunsch des Bundesrates
zur Vereinheitlichung des
Erscheinungsbildes eingeführt worden
sein
diese Vereinheitlichung halten die
Menschen in Dresden für völlig unnütz
ich weiß nicht was seine Verbesserung
sein soll das Haar steht genauso in der
Mitte ob auf weißen oder gelben
Untergrund hat und jeder weiß eine
Haltestelle ich glaube die Arbeit die
sich die Menschen machen könnte auch
besser investiert werden und auch das
Geld
bis jetzt sind erst 150 Schilder
erneuert worden es gibt also noch viel
überflüssige Arbeit zu tun für die
Montage Trupps